boo-yeah boo-yeah everybody we finally
got cyborg confirmed inside the live
action Titans universe of TV shows that
they're doing on this DC streaming
service so I'll explain what's going on
with the character how they're going to
use him introduce him and what that
means for the cyborg Justice League
movie that they originally announced a
couple years ago because this cyborg
inside the Titans universe is gonna be a
main character so if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the DC videos we're gonna be getting
a whole bunch of stuff later this year
we also found out what they're doing
with the Young Justice episodes I'll
explain that at the end of the video too
so first big thing the actors that they
cast to play cyborg inside this
live-action universe is Jovian Wade you
may remember him from Doctor Who or the
last purge movie I mostly remember him
from Doctor Who a couple years ago
they're calling him a main character but
he's going to debut on the Doom Patrol
TV show first that's a spinoff from
Titans so we'll get 13 episodes of
Titans the Doom Patrol will debut during
episode 5 through beast boy's character
because remember when he was changeling
he was a member of Doom Patrol initially
before he joined Teen Titans then after
that story they'll go off to their
spin-off TV show but that's not gonna
debut till like next spring maybe early
summer there'll be 13 episodes of that
but they haven't started shooting the
spin-off Doom Patrol TV series yet
that's why they just announced this
cyborg casting because he's gonna debut
on that TV show he's the one that shows
up and gives them their mission there's
this big problem they have to solve the
villain is supposed to be mr. nobody
because they're adapting Grant
Morrison's doomed patrol run for their
series arc so it'll be based on his
characters and the stories that he told
so if you're big Grant Morrison fan or
you're a big Grant Morrison Doom Patrol
fan they're gonna be doing all that
stuff the reason why that's a big deal
is because it's really trippy really
psychedelic and Grant Morrison is just
known for taking characters that nobody
knows anything about and doing really
awesome things with them but the big
deal is cyborg like people are like is
he going to be part of the Titans team
Doom Patrol is like when they spun Flash
out of arrow like you debut Barry Allen
on arrow then he goes off to his own TV
show called the flash same deal with
Doom Patrol but when cyborg shows up on
Doom Patrol he's not a member of the
Doom Patrol he's just gonna be a main
character which means he'll be in most
of the episodes which is why I think
they're leaving him free so that he can
join the Titans team in a future season
so you get classic Teen Titans and if it
wasn't clear the comic book run that
they're adapting for the Titans TV show
his classic Marv Wolfman Teen Titans
which was the New Teen Titans which was
like the first big run after their
initial debut where cyborg showed up so
they're starting out with classic cyborg
Teen Titans then of course he's probably
going to appear on that series
eventually but the thing is is they're
like slowly introducing characters like
Donna Troy is probably the next biggest
character that we're gonna meet the boy
from the circus
[Music]
please can you help me she wasn't in
that original trailer but that's just
because they can't throw too much at the
screen too quickly like you can't
introduce every single member in that
first episode so they're gonna slowly
ramp up which is also why there wasn't a
lot of Beast Boy in that trailer mostly
Robin dropping f-bombs the funny thing
about that too Jeff Jones was talking
all about the tone of the series he did
it be comic-con panel where he announced
what's going on with all these big DC
streaming shows mostly talking about
Titans Doom Patrol the star girl Justice
Society TV show that he's developing
right now that's right we're actually
gonna get just a society inside this DC
streaming service universe
so just remember that these TV shows are
setting up a separate continuity from
what's going on inside the arrowverse on
the CW and I largely think that's due to
tone like it has to be a little bit more
twee on the CW and even though the same
people that make flash and arrow are
making Titans they said that because the
tone was so different like this is why
they chose the DC streaming service to
do it there so just so they could tell
more hardcore stories that they wouldn't
be able to do on the CW network they're
really weird rules about what you can
actually show on TV during primetime on
those networks so the beauty of
streaming services like Netflix Hulu or
this new DC one is that there aren't any
regulations about that they can do
whatever they want to the way Geoff
Johns explained it like I said is that
they're starting out with classic Marv
Wolfman New Teen Titans for this Titans
TV show same kind of deal with Grant
Morrison's run and Doom Patrol but then
they're going in slightly different
directions with the characters and the
story so it'll be a little bit like the
way the flash treats the comic book
stories so they do the really iconic
stories but sometimes they'll remix
certain aspects of that like they're
doing a little bit more back to the
future with the flash season 5 in noir
Allen in the comics Barry had twins
neither one of them was named Nora so
just like slightly different spins on
the classic comic book runs so if you're
big Teen Titans comic book fan just
expect the same treatment so hive
Deathstroke brother blood Trigon they're
classic comic book stories will all be
big things but it won't be exactly like
it went down in the comics it'll just
feel very much like the comic book
stories it sounds like when cyborg shows
up he's gonna be a mixture of
live-action and CG so expecting to look
a little bit more real intangible than
rape fisher's cyborg who was like a pure
motion capture performance like he
literally walked around in his
underpants for that entire movie and
they just added all the effects in
post-production so a lot of people now
are like because they're using this
character on the TV show so much he's a
main character inside the Titans
universe does that mean
that they've cancelled the cyborg movie
because usually they don't let them do
the movie character so they have a big
movie coming up there were rumors that
ray Fisher was making some offhanded
remarks about them maybe not doing the
cyborg movie but DC
has not said anything about it since all
the Justice League stuff went down a
while ago and they reshuffled all the
people behind the scenes and then
announced their new film schedule so
like we learned all about the flash
movie that's gonna be shooting early
next year we learned about Wonder Woman
too which is in the middle of shooting
right now we even just heard about a
Supergirl movie that they're making we
learned all about the new Batman movie
but nowhere has anybody said anything
about cyborg so what's probably gonna
happen is is he'll continue to be a
character inside the DC movie universe
but he'll just show up in other people's
movies as of right now I don't think
that they plan to make that cyborg movie
so that could change down the road but I
just I think that's why it's okay for
them to use him on the TV shows so we
get some classic Teen Titans most of you
also probably saw the teaser trailer I
did because there was a post-credits
scene from Teen Titans go to the movies
with Teen Titans season 6 and they're
classic designs at the end of that early
prediction for that is that they stick
that on the DC streaming service because
the DC streaming service I believe is
getting that classic Teen Titans TV
series as far as I know Teen Titans go
is still very much on Cartoon Network
but the DC streaming service is trying
to buy up all the classic DC animation
all of the Batman TV series and movies
so it sounds like if we get new Teen
Titans season 6 that's will they'll put
it on that streaming service but the big
deal with Young Justice for those of you
wondering when we're gonna get that the
new info that we have says that it's
gonna be 26 episodes for season 3 but
what they're gonna do is they're gonna
break that into two blocks of 13
episodes so after they air 13 episodes
of Titans early next year they'll drop
13 episodes of Young Justice season 3
then we'll get the Doom Patrol TV series
then they're supposed to drop The Swamp
Thing live-action TV series then around
this time like late summer next year
they're supposed to drop the rest of
those 13 episodes of Young Justice
season 3 so hopefully that explains a
little bit about what's going on the
beta for all this is supposed to launch
later this month but they don't have an
exact day for that yet but I'm expecting
within the next two weeks right now
there's like a really big discount if
you sign up for a full year of the
service I'm assuming that once they
launch it there won't be that discount
anymore so post all your reactions in
the comment
below I know everybody just wants to see
what the cyborgs costume is gonna look
like it's probably gonna be a while
before we see any concept art or
anything like that but while you wait
for everything click here to learn all
about Sony's plans for crossing venom
over with Peter Parker spider-man
character down the line and click here
to rewatch The Young Justice season 3
trailer a billion more times thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]